A couple months ago, I got into a plane in San Diego. It was an overnight flight on JetBlue. And like everybody on the plane, I was anxious to get to sleep, right? And some people sat down and closed their eyes. And up at the front of the plane, a member of the crew kind of leaned on the bulkhead like a loiterer leaning on a lamppost and got on the PA.
几个月前，我在圣地亚哥登上一架飞机。那是捷蓝航空（JetBlue）的夜间航班。像机上所有人一样，我很想睡觉，对吧？有些人坐下来就闭上了眼睛。这时，飞机前舱的一名机组人员像个靠在路灯杆上的无业游民一样，斜倚在隔板上，打开了广播。
Good evening, folks. How's everybody doing tonight? Awesome, I hope.
晚上好，各位。大家今晚过得怎么样？希望你们都感觉很棒。
This recording was actually made by one of my coworkers, Lilly Sullivan, a few weeks later. She was on the same exact flight, and the same crew member gave the same speech, and Lilly recorded it. But really, what gets said is almost word for word the same as I heard.
这段录音其实是我同事莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）几周后录下来的。她正好在那趟航班上，同一位机组人员说了同样的话，莉莉就把它录了下来。说实话，她说的内容和我听到的几乎一字不差。
My name is Anne, you guys. And I was just out walking around the airplane, and they're throwing the last of your-- I mean, um, I'm sorry about that. I didn't mean to say throwing. I used to work over at American, you know. Old habits die hard. So what I meant to say was, they were lovingly and gently placing your bags in the lower belly, and then we'll be pushing back from the gate on time.
大家好，我叫安。我刚才在飞机上走了一圈，他们正在把你们最后的行李——我是说，呃，抱歉。我不是故意说“扔”的。我以前在美联航工作过，你们知道的。旧习难改。我想说的是，他们正在深情、轻柔地把你们的行李放进货舱，之后我们就会按时离开登机口。
The night I was there, everybody was like, what is this? Like, was that a joke? Was she just mocking another airline, American Airlines? We were like drowsy kittens waking up to the fact that, oh, something was going on.
我当时在那里的时候，大家都在想，这是什么情况？这是在开玩笑吗？她是在嘲讽另一家航空公司，比如美国航空吗？我们就像刚睡醒的小猫一样，意识到有些事情正在发生。
But you know what the really good news is, you guys? I'm going to be your pilot flying to New York tonight.
但你们知道真正的好消息是什么吗，各位？今晚飞往纽约的航班，我将担任你们的飞行员。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
I know. Isn't that awesome? I know. Thank you. Thank you. I know. I just graduated pilot training yesterday and I'm very excited for my first flight tonight. I'm just kidding. I've been flying airplanes since I was 17. Can you believe that? I know. These last two years have been very exciting, so. That wasn't that funny.
我知道。这不是很棒吗？我知道。谢谢。谢谢。我知道。我昨天才刚完成飞行训练，我很激动能执飞今晚的首次航班。我开玩笑呢。我从17岁就开始开飞机了。你们敢相信吗？我知道。过去这两年非常令人兴奋，所以……那笑话没那么好笑。
OK. She's not the greatest comedian, but there was something about her swagger, like her sheer joy in what she was doing, that transcended the actual material she was putting out. And I swear the whole plane was with her. Lilly says this happened on her flight, too. Nobody normally wants to listen to a pilot's speech, but she had the element of surprise. It was just not a normal speech.
好吧，她不是最伟大的喜剧演员，但她那种潇洒的态度，那种对自己所做之事纯粹的快乐，超越了她所说的实际内容。我发誓，全机的人都支持她。莉莉说这种事也发生在她的航班上。通常没人想听飞行员的演讲，但她掌握了惊喜的元素。那根本不是正常的广播。
At one point-- I think it's the thing you're about to hear-- I turned to the stranger sitting next to me and asked, is she drunk?
有那么一刻——我想就是你们接下来要听到的那一刻——我转向坐在旁边的陌生人问道，她是不是喝醉了？
No. I used to fly the big airplanes over at American and TWA. American said I didn't have a personality, so they sent me over here to JetBlue. Can you believe that? Hey, real quick story while they're finishing up.
没醉。我以前在美联航和环球航空飞过大型客机。美联航说我没有个性，所以就把我打发到捷蓝航空来了。你们敢相信吗？嘿，趁他们还在整理，讲个小故事。
"The personality to be a pilot," is how I think she worded it the night I saw her.
“当飞行员的个性”，我想她是这么形容那天我见她时的那番话的。
Air travel is this very orderly, intentionally ritualized, and impersonal kind of corporate experience. But she was just the opposite of corporate. She was like a person. And so I tracked her down to ask how did this happen, exactly. Like, what was she trying to do?
航空旅行是一种非常有序、刻意仪式化且非个人的企业体验。但她与企业化截然不同。她就像个普通人。所以我追踪到她，想问问这一切究竟是怎么发生的。就像，她到底想做什么？
Well, her name is Anne Aldrich, and her answer to the question what are you trying to do could not be more straightforward.
好吧，她的名字叫安·奥尔德里奇（Anne Aldrich），她对“你到底想做什么”这个问题的回答再直接不过了。
To make people come back to JetBlue. That's a very good question. I want them to come back and fly with us. In the short term, the people that are scared in the back--
为了让人们回到捷蓝航空。这是个非常好的问题。我希望他们回来乘坐我们的航班。短期来看，机舱后部那些感到害怕的乘客——
Oh. When Anne says "the back," what she's referring to is the place that you and I call the airplane-- the part we sit in.
哦。当安说“后部”时，她指的是你我称之为飞机的地方——我们坐的那部分。
The people that are scared in the back of flying, they'll come back up to me at the end of the flight and say, I wasn't scared because you made me laugh. I try-- I mean, I try to be funny.
那些在机舱后部感到害怕的乘客，在飞行结束时会过来对我说，我不怕了，因为你让我笑了。我尝试……我的意思是，我尝试变得幽默。
Just thinking about the reaction of your passengers, I remember a White House correspondent telling me once that there's a whole class of jokes that aren't actually funny except when you're standing in front of a room and you're the President of the United States making those jokes.
一想到你乘客的反应，我就想起一位白宫记者曾对我说过，有一整类笑话，除非你是美国总统站在房间前面讲这些笑话，否则它们其实一点都不好笑。
[LAUGHING] Right.
[笑声] 对。
And I wonder if that's true for airline pilots, as well.
我不知道这对于航空公司飞行员来说是否也适用。
You know, I certainly wouldn't use my routine anywhere else. But I'm a better pilot than I am a comedian. That's for sure. And I think it's funny because, in 2017, people still find it very uncommon to see a woman flying an airplane. On one of my spiels, I say, yeah, I'm going to be your pilot flying to New York tonight. And you see everybody's heads flip up. And I go, yeah, that gets more attention than "there's been a wallet left out on the jetway." I just kind of make a joke about it.
你知道，我肯定不会在其他地方用我的这套说辞。但我是一个比喜剧演员更优秀的飞行员。那是一定的。而且我觉得这很有趣，因为在2017年，人们仍然觉得看到女性驾驶飞机是非常罕见的。在我的开场白中，我说，是的，我将是今晚飞往纽约的飞行员。你会看到所有人的头都抬了起来。然后我说，是的，这比“登机廊桥上落了一个钱包”更引人注目。我只是拿这事儿开了个玩笑。
And is it actually pretty rare?
这真的挺罕见的吗？
It's not as rare as it used to be. When I first got on with TWA, there was less than 10 of us gals in an airline that had, I think, at the time, almost 7,000 pilots.
已经没以前那么罕见了。我刚加入环球航空时，在那家拥有大概7000名飞行员的航空公司里，我们这些女飞行员还不到10个。
These days, nationally, about 5% of commercial airline pilots are women, according to the Air Line Pilots Association. Anne flew for 10 years for TWA until it was bought out by American, where she was till layoffs after 9/11. She's been with JetBlue the past 15 years. When she's not flying, she runs a nonprofit animal rescue shelter that she created in Phoenix, where she lives.
根据航空飞行员协会的数据，如今，全国约有5%的商用客机飞行员是女性。安在环球航空飞行了10年，直到它被美国航空收购，她在那里一直工作到9/11事件后的裁员。过去15年她一直在捷蓝航空。不飞行的时候，她经营着一家自己创办的动物救援收容所，就在她居住的凤凰城。
I hadn't seen many pilots actually come into the cabin to talk to the passengers at the beginning of a flight. But Anne says that, when she started at JetBlue in the airline's early days, they encouraged pilots to do it.
我还没见过多少飞行员在起飞前进入客舱与乘客交谈。但安说，当她刚到捷蓝航空的早期，公司鼓励飞行员这样做。
And at first, I was kind of nervous about doing it. I would go to the back, give the flight time, say welcome aboard, and I was very stoic and trying to be as professional as possible. And then I rode on a few Southwest flights, and saw-- I don't remember what the captain's name was, but he was hilarious. And a number of the flight attendants do it at Southwest. And I thought, I can do this.
起初，我对这样做感到有点紧张。我会走到后舱，告诉大家飞行时间，欢迎登机，那时我非常严肃，尽量表现得尽可能专业。后来我坐了几次西南航空的航班，看到——我不记得机长的名字了，但他非常风趣。西南航空的很多乘务员也会这么做。我想，我也可以做到。
But in imitating that pilot, and trying to be funny like he was, she started to express this part of herself that was not like what you usually hear. For instance, in her preflight spiel, she tells this one story about how when she was a kid in 1970, back when the number of female airline pilots in the United States was exactly zero-- there were none at all-- she told her first grade teacher she wanted to grow up to be an airline pilot.
但在模仿那位飞行员并试图变得风趣时，她开始表达自己不为人知的一面。例如，在她飞行前的广播中，她讲了一个故事：1970年她还是个孩子的时候，当时美国女性客机飞行员的数量恰好为零——一个都没有——她告诉一年级的老师，她长大后想成为一名飞行员。
She goes, you can't be an airline pilot. So a couple of years ago, my son's sitting in first grade. Teacher knows his mom's an airline pilot for JetBlue. His dad's a firefighter out in Phoenix, Arizona. Teacher says, Johnny, what do you want to be when you grow up? What do you think my son says? He goes, I want to be a firefighter. Teacher says, you don't want to be an airline pilot? He goes, airline pilot? Are you kidding? That's a girl's job.
老师说，你不能当飞行员。所以几年前，我儿子在读一年级。老师知道他妈妈是捷蓝航空的飞行员。他爸爸是亚利桑那州凤凰城的消防员。老师说，强尼，你长大后想做什么？你们猜我儿子怎么说？他说，我想当消防员。老师说，你不想当飞行员吗？他说，飞行员？你在开玩笑吗？那是女生的工作。
I asked her about all the cracks that she makes against American Airlines and she said she really has nothing against American Airlines at all. The jokes just play better if you name a specific airline. And she said it's not true that American Airlines told her she didn't have the personality to be a pilot.
我问她关于她对美国航空的所有挖苦，她说她真的对美国航空没有任何偏见。这些笑话如果点名具体的航空公司会效果更好。而且她说，美国航空说她“没有个性”是不真实的。
You know what? I've got to be honest with you, Ira. The captain that was on Southwest, I stole that from him because he said the exact same thing. "American said I didn't have a personality, so they sent me over here to Southwest." So I actually stole that line from him.
你知道吗？艾拉，我得诚实地告诉你。西南航空那位机长，我是从他那儿偷学的，因为他说过一模一样的话。“美联航说我没有个性，所以把我打发到西南航空来了。”所以我其实是从他那儿偷来的台词。
But my favorite part of Anne's on-board stand-up routine-- the most remarkable and, I think, most idiosyncratic part of it-- is this. In this setting, where everybody seems so stressed out and not so happy at all-- I mean, that is what so much of travel is; hauling from place to place, waiting on line, worrying about all the things that can delay you and go wrong-- Anne unleashes, in this very pure way, her total enthusiasm for flying and just the incredible fact that we fly.
但我最喜欢安在机上的脱口秀表演中——最引人注目，我认为也是最独特的部分——是这一点。在这个每个人看起来都压力重重、一点也不开心的环境下——我的意思是，这就是大部分旅行的样子；从一个地方拖着行李到另一个地方，排队等候，担心所有可能导致延误或出错的事情——安以一种非常纯粹的方式，释放了她对飞行的全部热情，以及我们能飞行这一不可思议的事实。
Anyways, you boarded a super hot jet. I love this airplane. It's the Airbus A321. It's all fly-by-wire. Aside from the 727, it's my favorite airplane. We're taken off here in San Diego. We're taking off Runway 27, you guys. We're taking off a weight of 175,000 pounds. Isn't that awesome? Folks, when we leave the concrete, we're doing 165 miles per hour. Get the gear and flaps up. I'm picking it up to 200 and out of 10,000 feet. You know what? FAA says I can go as fast as I want.
总之，你们登上一架超级酷的飞机。我爱这架飞机。它是空客A321。它全部是电传操纵的。除了727，这是我最喜欢的飞机。我们现在在圣地亚哥起飞。我们正在使用27号跑道起飞，各位。我们的起飞重量是17.5万磅。这不是很棒吗？各位，当我们离开地面时，我们的速度是每小时165英里。收起起落架和襟翼。我会加速到200英里，飞到1万英尺以上。你知道吗？联邦航空局说我可以想飞多快就飞多快。
On the night I saw you, you named the runway we were going to land at in New York, and you said it was your favorite runway.
在我见到你的那天晚上，你报出了我们要降落在纽约的那条跑道，你说那是你最喜欢的跑道。
Oh, I know. We probably did the Canarsie arrival onto Runway 13 Left. It's a very technical arrival. It used to be a VOR. Now it's an RNAV arrival. But you come in, it's this roundabout turning, and it's very precise. And you have to be 1,000 feet abeam Runway 13 Right. And you have to be 500 feet over the hotel. And then you get the wind coming off from the buildings. There's always a crosswind when you're landing on 13 Left. And I love that approach because it's difficult. It takes some skill and I love it. I love it. It's fun.
哦，我知道。我们大概是执行了卡纳西（Canarsie）进场程序降落在13左跑道。这是一个非常有技术含量的进场。以前它是VOR导航，现在是RNAV导航。你进来的时候，是一个圆形的转弯，非常精确。你必须在13右跑道横梁外1000英尺处。你必须在酒店上方500英尺处。然后你会遇到从建筑物吹来的风。降落在13左时总是有侧风。我喜欢那种进场，因为它很难。需要一些技巧，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。这很有趣。
She still flies gliders in an old crop duster where her hair blows in the wind. But what she loves most about flying is when it takes real skill, where she really has to plan around weather, where she has to plan tricky descents.
她仍然在旧的喷洒农药飞机上驾驶滑翔机，头发在风中吹拂。但她最喜欢飞行的地方在于它需要真正的技术，她必须围绕天气进行规划，必须规划棘手的下降路径。
Going into, like, San Diego, which has this huge displaced threshold--
进入圣地亚哥这种地方，那儿有一个巨大的位移阈值——
Whatever that is. Or flying into Chicago O'Hare, which is so, so busy.
不管那是什么意思。或者飞往芝加哥奥黑尔机场，那里非常非常繁忙。
You ask any pilot in the radio traffic on Chicago. If you're not paying attention, the controllers just send you out on a vector to nowhere for a little while if you miss listening to them. Yeah. And so you've got to be on your toes.
你去问芝加哥无线电通讯里的任何飞行员。如果你不注意，管制员就会因为你没听清他们的指令，把你送到没人的航向上去待一会儿。是的。所以你必须时刻保持警惕。
What are you talking about? You mean they just send you out into the air?
你在说什么？你是说他们只是把你送到空中去？
Yep. No more soup for you. You don't answer, and you're going out. They'll say, JetBlue, fly heading such and such. Maintain that altitude. And they send you away for a little bit and then they bring you back in. So I love that. I love that. I'm on my toes. I'm listening. OK, I'm ready.
是的。没汤喝了。你不回答，你就得走。他们会说，“捷蓝航空，航向是多少。保持高度。”他们把你支走一会儿，然后再把你带回来。所以我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我保持警惕。我在听。好了，我准备好了。
Why do so many people complain about airline travel, do you think?
你觉得为什么那么多人抱怨航空旅行？
You know, somebody who rides in the back a lot because I have to commute to New York for work, it can be a jungle back there. You've got people changing the babies' diapers on the tray table. And when I'm in uniform, I'm like, how do I say politely and diplomatically, people eat on this thing and you're changing your, you know? And Ira, I've seen people clipping their toenails, burping, you know. It's not like what it used to be.
你知道，作为一个经常坐在后舱的人，因为我工作需要通勤去纽约，那里简直是丛林。你会看到有人在餐桌上给婴儿换尿布。当我在制服状态时，我在想，我该如何礼貌而委婉地说，人们还得在这上面吃饭，而你却在换你的……你懂的？艾拉，我见过有人剪脚趾甲、打嗝，你知道。这已经不是以前的样子了。
I think it's funny to hear you say this because I feel like, as you're saying this, the thing I'm thinking is, the passengers, when they talk about what's terrible about plane travel is they blame it on the airlines. And I feel like, oh, I'm talking to you and I feel like you're totally blaming it on the passengers.
我觉得听你这么说很有意思，因为我感觉，当你在说这些的时候，我在想，乘客们在谈论航空旅行有多糟糕时，他们会责怪航空公司。而我觉得，哦，我在和你聊天，我感觉你完全在把锅甩给乘客。
[LAUGHING] Well, you're just in a tight space with a lot of people, that, I'm not sure, but everybody seems to not always be on their best behavior, and I think it's because of all the stress, I guess, of getting there.
[笑声] 嗯，你只是被困在一个人很多、空间狭窄的地方，我不确定，但每个人似乎并不总是表现得最好，我想这可能是因为到达目的地所带来的压力，我猜。
Most people on her flight seem stressed out when they get on the plane, Anne says.
安说，她航班上的大多数乘客在登机时看起来都压力很大。
Well, today on our radio show, we have stories for things that happen in transit that create that stress. We have people traveling from spot to spot, being stopped, being ticketed, being delayed in unusually dramatic ways here and on the other side of the world. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
嗯，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有一些关于运输中产生压力的故事。我们有乘客从一个点到另一个点，被拦下、被开罚单、以异常戏剧性的方式被延误，这里还有世界的那一头。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
So what do you guys think? Let's put the pedal to the metal. Drive this baby like a rental car out to-- OK. OK. I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
那么你们觉得呢？让我们踩下油门。像开租来的车一样把这宝贝开到——好的。好的。我开玩笑呢。我开玩笑呢。
Tray tables up. Chairs in the upright position, everybody. And stay with us.
小桌板收起。座椅靠背调直，各位。请继续收听。
Act One, The Most Expected Delay in Northern Ohio.
第一幕，俄亥俄州北部最被预期的延误。
So we heard about this tiny stretch of roadway in Ohio. It's kind of infamous in the area. Many, many people have been delayed there over the years, or maybe waylaid is a better word for it. They've certainly paid the price for going there. Our producer Sean Cole explains.
我们听说俄亥俄州有一小段路，在当地很有名。多年来，许多人都在那里被延误，或者用“被截住”这个词可能更恰当。他们肯定为经过那里付出了代价。我们的制作人肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）来解释一下。
This stretch of road is on Interstate 71 just outside Cleveland. It's about 400 yards long, 1,200 or so feet, take less than half a minute to drive it. And it happens to run through the municipal limits of an itty bitty village known as Linndale. And here's the thing everybody knows about Linndale. If you drive down this little stretch of road and you're speeding, the Linndale police will pull you over and give you a ticket. For decades, it's been the most aggressively policed 440-yard stretch of Interstate 71 around. And you have to pass through it to get from the airport to downtown Cleveland, so tourists on their way to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame or whatever get pulled over. And if you ask people who live in the Cleveland area, Linndale is basically a speed trap masquerading as a town.
这段路位于克利夫兰郊外的71号州际公路上。它大约有400码长，1200英尺左右，开车通过不到半分钟。它恰好经过一个名为林代尔（Linndale）的小村庄的市政范围。每个人都知道林代尔的一件事：如果你开车经过这段路时超速，林代尔警察就会把你拦下并开罚单。几十年来，这直是71号州际公路最激进的440码执法路段。你必须穿过它才能从机场到达克利夫兰市中心，所以去摇滚名人堂之类地方的游客经常被拦下。如果你问住在这个地区的当地人，林代尔基本上就是一个伪装成城镇的超速陷阱。
Have you gotten a ticket going through Linndale?
你在经过林代尔时被开过罚单吗？
Like four.
大概四次。
Oh, I've had them. They're crooks.
噢，我中过招。他们就是骗子。
Myself. My sister got one.
我自己。我姐姐也被开过。
My wife has gotten a ticket in there.
我妻子在那里收到过罚单。
Everybody that comes to my house, I tell them, go slow when you go through Linndale because they will give you a ticket.
每个来我家的人，我都会告诉他们，经过林代尔时慢点，因为他们会给你开罚单。
Yes, they were petty. They blurped me.
是的，他们很刻薄。他们对我鸣笛拦截。
They blurped you, meaning they pulled you over.
他们鸣笛拦截你，意思是他们把你拦下了。
Yes. Like coming off on 130th right here, thirsty. I was so mad.
是的。就像从130号出口出来这里，很渴。我当时气坏了。
We first heard about Linndale from Mark Gardner, a criminal defense attorney who's represented people in court who've gotten tickets in Linndale. He, himself, has never gotten a ticket on that stretch of road. Says he knows better.
我们最早从马克·加德纳（Mark Gardner）那里听说林代尔，他是一位刑事辩护律师，曾代表在林代尔收到罚单的人出庭。他自己从未在那段路上收到过罚单。他说他知道该怎么做。
As soon as you see certain signs, like West 65th, I'm approaching Linndale, your foot automatically comes off the gas and you look down just to make sure that you're not going to get pulled over.
一旦你看到特定的标志，比如西65街，我知道我快到林代尔了，你的脚会自动离开油门，你会低头确认自己不会被拦下。
Was that muscle memory for you?
那是你的肌肉记忆吗？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
But the reason Mark first told us about Linndale isn't just that they hand out a lot of tickets. It's because of this epic, still-ongoing battle that's developed over the past two decades between Linndale and the Ohio State Legislature, a petty political tit-for-tat that, if it were about something more high stakes-- like health care, nuclear weapons, or something-- would be horrifying. But since it's about speeding tickets, it plays as comedy rather than tragedy.
但马克向我们介绍林代尔的原因不仅仅是因为他们开出很多罚单。而是因为在过去二十年里，林代尔和俄亥俄州议会之间爆发了一场史诗般的、仍在持续的战斗。这是一场琐碎的政治报复，如果它涉及的事情影响更重大——比如医疗保健、核武器之类的——那会很可怕。但因为它只是关于超速罚单，所以它更像是一出喜剧而非悲剧。
See, according to the 2010 census, Linndale is a village of 179 people. It's got 35 houses in it, 11 businesses. In some years, it's brought in almost $1 million in speeding violations on the freeway. Again, that's 35 houses, nearly $1 million in speeding tickets-- the vast majority of its budget. It's a municipality that, arguably, wouldn't exist, wouldn't have a budget, or barely any money at all, if not for speeding tickets. And the Ohio Legislature basically treats Linndale as a parasite, living off the lead-footedness of northern Ohioans. So the players are a town that has eight streets in it and a powerful body of lawmakers who thinks its laws are being enforced not wisely and too well.
看，根据2010年的人口普查，林代尔是一个只有179人的村庄。里面有35户人家，11家企业。有些年份，它在高速公路上收取的超速违章罚款将近100万美元。再说一遍，那是35户人家，将近100万美元的超速罚单——这占了他们预算的绝大部分。这是一个可以说如果没有超速罚单，就不会存在、没有预算、甚至几乎没有钱的城市。俄亥俄州立法机构基本上把林代尔视为寄生虫，靠俄亥俄州北部那些“重脚”司机的罚款为生。所以，参与这场斗争的双方是一个只有八条街的城镇，以及一个强大的立法机构，后者认为林代尔的法律执行得既不明智也不合理。
But the story actually starts before Interstate 71 was even built.
但这个故事其实早在71号州际公路建成之前就开始了。
Linndale has always been the burr up somebody's ass ever since I can remember.
自我记事起，林代尔一直就像是某些人心里的芒刺。
Mike Toczek was the mayor of Linndale back in the late '80s and early '90s. After that, he became clerk of Linndale's Mayor's Court, which is just a local town court that handles traffic violations and other low-level offenses. He's 68 and has lived in Linndale most of his life. And the way he describes it-- and it seems to be true-- Linndale has always been a town on the hustle. He remembers back when it was a den of illegal gambling houses. Says he used to like watching all the gamblers jump into their cars and zoom away minutes before the sheriff arrived for a raid. Linndale was also a place, at one point, you could buy fireworks, which were illegal in Cleveland. And when Mike was a kid, the village had more than twice the residents it has now.
迈克·托切克（Mike Toczek）在80年代末和90年代初是林代尔的镇长。在那之后，他成了林代尔镇长法庭的书记员，这只是一个处理交通违章和其他轻微违法行为的当地城镇法庭。他68岁了，一生大部分时间都住在林代尔。按照他的描述——而且看起来是真的——林代尔一直是一个靠钻营求生的城镇。他记得以前这里是非法赌博场所的窝点。他说他以前很喜欢看那些赌徒在警察突袭前几分钟跳进车里狂奔而去。林代尔曾经还是个可以买到烟花的地方，在克利夫兰那是违法的。迈克小时候，村里的居民人数是现在的两倍多。
The freeway, Interstate 71, came through in about-- in the late '60s and cut the village literally in half and took out a ton of homes and businesses. In fact, it took our house. Now, there are some rumors that I heard when I was young that one of the planners for the freeway didn't like Linndale and the state wanted to get rid of us and rerouted the 71 through the middle of Linndale.
71号州际公路在60年代末穿过村庄，字面上把村庄一分为二，拆掉了大量的房屋和企业。事实上，它拆掉了我们的房子。其实我年轻时听到过一些传闻，说高速公路的规划者之一不喜欢林代尔，州政府想摆脱我们，于是把71号线绕道穿过了林代尔的中间。
It's tempting to think that the village started ticketing people on the freeway out of revenge, to consciously be a burr in the ass-phalt. But Mike says it was more just an opportunity. Linndale doesn't even have access to 71. There's no off-ramp that leads to the village. Nonetheless, a 1967 article in the Cleveland Press called the freeway Bonanza Boulevard for Linndale.
人们很容易认为这个村庄开始在高速公路上开罚单是为了报复，为了有意识地成为一种干扰。但迈克说这更多是一个机会。林代尔甚至没有连接71号公路的通道。没有通往村庄的出口。尽管如此，1967年《克利夫兰新闻》的一篇文章将高速公路称为林代尔的“富矿大道”。
There's this scene where the mayor at the time, who looked like Paulie from Goodfellas, keeps ringing up $28 speeding citations in the Mayor's Court. He has this real f-you, pay-me attitude about it when people complain. And he throws up his hands at the assertion that Linndale only tickets people for quick cash, saying the village is bound by the state to patrol 71-- which, we called the Ohio Department of Transportation-- it doesn't seem to be true. That mayor later went to prison on gambling and bribery charges. Mike Toczek took over as mayor of Linndale in 1985.
当时有一幕，那个长得像电影《好家伙》里保利（Paulie）的镇长，在镇长法庭上一遍又一遍地开出28美元的超速罚单。当人们抱怨时，他有一种“去你的，交钱吧”的态度。他对于林代尔只为快钱开罚单的指控摊开双手表示无奈，称村庄被州政府要求巡逻71号公路——对此，我们致电俄亥俄州交通部核实——那似乎不是真的。那位镇长后来因赌博和贿赂罪入狱。迈克·托切克于1985年接任林代尔镇长。
I think the police department realized that the main source of income was tickets. And some of the tickets they issued-- and I remember this clearly-- a person would get a ticket. He'd get five tickets. He'd get one for no taillight, one for unsafe vehicle because he didn't have a taillight, another one for something related to that, and another one. And I called the chief over, and I says, we're not doing this. I says, we are not doing this. You're screwing the people. You want to give them a ticket for no taillight? That's it. That's fine.
我想警察局意识到主要收入来源是罚单。他们开出的一些罚单——我记得很清楚——一个人会收到罚单。他会收到五张。一张是因为没有尾灯，一张是因为车辆不安全因为他没有尾灯，另一张是跟那相关的，还有另一张。我把警长叫过来，我说，我们不能这样做。我说，我们绝不能这样做。你在坑人。你想因为没有尾灯给他们开罚单？那行，那没问题。
But as this is America, there are enough of us just speeding to make a good living off of. And then, in 1994, this curious piece of legislation started working its way through the Ohio House and Senate. It had to do with local police departments handing out traffic violations on the freeway. Among other things, the bill said local police can't hand out speeding tickets on I-71 if fewer than 880 yards of the freeway actually goes through their town, which is twice the yardage that went through Linndale. And local police can't hand out tickets on the freeway if their town doesn't have access to the freeway. Also, it said your town can't begin with L and rhyme with Shwinndale
但既然是在美国，靠我们这些超速的人足以过上好日子。然后，在1994年，这一条奇怪的法案开始在俄亥俄州众议院和参议院通过。它与当地警察局在高速公路上处理交通违章有关。在其他条款中，该法案规定，如果高速公路穿过其城镇的长度不到880码，当地警察就不能在71号公路上开出超速罚单，这正好是穿过林代尔长度的两倍。而且，如果该镇没有连接高速公路的入口，当地警察也不能在高速公路上开罚单。此外，它还规定，你的城镇名称不能以L开头并且与“Shwinndale”押韵。
OK, it didn't say that. But it may as well have. This is Mark Gardner again, the lawyer who first told us about Linndale.
好吧，它没这么说。但它和这么说也差不多了。这就是马克·加德纳，那位最早告诉我们林代尔情况的律师。
It was very clear. It was very obvious. But nobody that I knew had any great sympathy for Linndale. I can only assume that there was some triggering event. And rumor has it that a legislator or one of his well-to-do constituents complained, and that's what got the law rolling. I don't have proof of that. I'm just assuming.
这非常清楚。这非常明显。但我认识的任何人都对林代尔没有太多的同情。我只能假设发生了某种触发事件。传闻说，一位立法者或他的一位富有选民抱怨了，这就是促使法律出台的原因。我没有证据。我只是假设。
Luckily, I do have proof of that. Allow me to introduce former Ohio State Representative Ed Kasputis, the guy who first drafted the legislation.
幸运的是，我有证据。允许我介绍前俄亥俄州众议员埃德·卡斯普蒂斯（Ed Kasputis），他是第一个起草该法案的人。
I was sharing office space with a printer. And one of the employees, he got a ticket.
当时我正和一个打印机共享办公室空间。其中一个员工收到了一张罚单。
The office space in question was in Cleveland. That's where he practiced law. And one day around the water cooler-- again, this is 1994-- this guy working for the printing company says--
那个办公室空间位于克利夫兰。那就是他从事法律工作的地方。有一天在饮水机旁——再次强调，那是1994年——那个给印刷公司工作的人说——
You're not going to believe what happened to me last night. And we're like, what happened? And he's like, I went to this Mayor's Court, and if people couldn't pay, they put them in a room and gave them a phone, and they said, start dialing for dollars. And if you don't come up with money tonight, you're going to county jail. And it's like, no, you've got to be embellishing. And he's like, no. You've got to check it out. I said, all right, it's time to go and be undercover state rep.
你绝对不会相信我昨晚经历了什么。我们问，发生了什么？他说，我去了这个镇长法庭，如果人们付不起钱，他们就把人关进一个房间，给他们一个电话，说，开始拨号搞钱吧。如果你今晚拿不出钱，你就得去县监狱。我们说，不，你肯定在夸大其词。他说，不。你们一定要去查查。我说，好吧，是时候去当个卧底州代表了。
So Ed puts on his disguise, which according to him is a pair of blue jeans, and drives to Linndale's Village Hall on the one day a week everybody goes to contest their tickets or just to pay them. And he sees what looks like officials handing a phone to one defendant after another. The story seemed to check out. Except for one part.
于是埃德穿上了伪装，根据他的说法，那是一条蓝色牛仔裤，开车去了林代尔的村政厅，那是每周每个人去辩解罚单或仅仅是交罚款的一天。他看到了看起来像是工作人员的人把电话交给一个接一个被告。这个故事似乎是真实的。除了一个部分。
They don't take you to county jail.
他们不会带你去县监狱。
But they threaten you, and you and I would not like to go to county jail for a night. I then started to research the city of Linndale and confirmed that this is this little mouse that roared that is basically financing the entire government on traffic tickets. And as a policymaker, I just didn't think that was a fair way to treat people. Because 9 times out of 10, or 10 times out of 10, these were citizens that couldn't vote the mayor out of office.
但他们威胁你，你和我都不会想在县监狱过夜。我随后开始研究林代尔市，并确认这是一个咆哮的小老鼠，基本上靠交通罚单资助整个政府。作为一个决策者，我只是觉得这不是对待人们的公平方式。因为十之八九，这些都是无法投票罢免镇长的公民。
That is, Linndale was mostly ticketing non-Linndalers. In fact, Linndale is not in Ed Kasputis' district, and as he started writing the legislation, it came out that he, himself, had gotten a ticket in Linndale and just paid it without even ever looking at it. And the other thing that really galled him was the fact that there was no ramp in Linndale to and from the highway, that Linndale police had to drive out of Linndale, through part of Cleveland, and then work their way back to that little infamous patch on 71.
也就是说，林代尔主要是在给非林代尔人开罚单。事实上，林代尔不在埃德·卡斯普蒂斯的选区内，当他开始撰写立法时，有人透露他自己也在林代尔收到过罚单，并且连看都没看就交了钱。让他感到恼火的另一件事是，林代尔没有连接高速公路的进出口匝道，林代尔警察必须开车离开林代尔，穿过克利夫兰的一部分，然后再折回到71号公路上那段臭名昭著的区域。
And you see, from a public policy standpoint, that makes no sense, if you have to leave your city to go back in on the fiction of, we're protecting our citizens. No. The Serengeti--
你看，从公共政策的角度来看，如果你必须离开你的城市再折回，却虚构出“我们在保护我们的公民”的说法，那是说不通的。不。塞伦盖蒂——
That's what Ed calls the freeway. The Serengeti. Speeders are gazelles.
这就是埃德对高速公路的称呼。塞伦盖蒂。超速者是羚羊。
The Serengeti has people from all over the world running on it. The people in Linndale-- there's like a stoplight at Burger King, and that's kind of it.
塞伦盖蒂上有来自世界各地的人在奔跑。林代尔人——那儿有个汉堡王的红绿灯，差不多就这些。
You mean, in giving tickets to speeders on that little stretch of 71, they're not doing anything to actually protect their residents?
你的意思是，给71号那一段的超速者开罚单，他们其实并没有在保护他们的居民？
No. Not at all. They should be driving around, protecting their residents from crime, instead of trying to be the Ohio State Highway Patrol for 220 yards.
没有。一点也没有。他们应该开车四处巡逻，保护居民免受犯罪侵害，而不是试图在220码的路段上当俄亥俄州公路巡警。
Again, it's 400 yards. And the Burger King closed down a long time ago. Anyway, Ed's bill passed. It became against the law for the village to enforce the law on I-71-- or at least the law against speeding. I asked Mike Toczek, the former mayor, what he thought when he heard about the bill.
再说一遍，那是400码。而且汉堡王很久以前就关门了。总之，埃德的法案通过了。村庄在71号公路上执法——或者至少是对超速执法——变成违法了。我问迈克·托切克，那位前镇长，当他听说这个法案时怎么想。
Oh, again.
哦，又来了。
That's what you thought is, oh, again?
你当时的想法是“又来了”吗？
Oh, again. Approximately once every 10 years, somebody would come after us for something.
哦，又来了。大约每10年左右，就会有人因为某件事来找我们麻烦。
Before, it was the gambling. Now it was handing out too many speeding tickets. He says people used to approach him-- reporters like me-- and say, what are you guys doing in business with this ticket racket?
以前是赌博。现在是开了太多超速罚单。他说以前人们经常接近他——像我这样的记者——问，你们这群人搞这种罚单敲诈生意是干什么？
I says, you know what? You want to put us out of business? Don't speed. Just stop speeding. Everybody in the Cleveland area knows about Linndale. If you know it's there, and you know they give tickets, and you're still, if you will, stupid enough to speed, then you deserve it.
我说，你知道吗？你想让我们破产？别超速。别超速就行了。克利夫兰地区的所有人都知道林代尔。如果你知道它在那里，而且知道他们会开罚单，如果你还是，怎么说呢，傻到去超速，那你就活该。
That's Linndale's position in this whole battle in a nutshell. You don't like it, then just follow the rules. We don't set the speed limit. All we're doing is enforcing the rules imposed by the state. And the state's position is, no. You're abusing the rules we made for your personal enrichment. We don't like the way you're enforcing them. And we can do something about it.
这就是林代尔在这场斗争中整个立场的缩影。你不喜欢它，那就遵守规矩。我们没有设定限速。我们所做的只是执行州政府制定的规则。而州政府的立场是，不。你在滥用我们为你制定的规则来中饱私囊。我们不喜欢你执行规则的方式。而且我们对此可以采取行动。
Again, former State Rep Ed Kasputis.
再次请出前州众议员埃德·卡斯普蒂斯。
Everybody needs a check and balance. What's the check and balance for Linndale? I would say one of them is the legislature. That's all. And what's a check and balance on the legislature? The court system.
每个人都需要监督和制衡。林代尔的监督制衡是什么？我会说是立法机构。就这么简单。而对立法机构的监督制衡是什么？法庭系统。
In other words, Linndale sued-- together with another community that was similar-- for their right to ticket people on their stretch of roadway. The argument was that Ed Kasputis' bill violated the Ohio State Constitution, which says that cities and villages can govern themselves as long as their local regulations don't conflict with state law. The appeal process lasted about five years, during which time, Linndale was allowed to keep pulling people over on 71. Finally, in 1999, the Ohio State Supreme Court ruled in Linndale's favor. Round 1-- Linndale.
换句话说，林代尔提起诉讼——连同另一个情况相似的社区一起——争取他们在自己道路路段上开罚单的权利。辩论的焦点是埃德·卡斯普蒂斯的法案违反了俄亥俄州宪法，该宪法规定，城市和村庄可以治理自己，只要其当地法规不与州法律冲突。上诉过程持续了大约五年，在此期间，林代尔被允许继续在71号公路上拦截车辆。最终，1999年，俄亥俄州最高法院做出有利于林代尔的裁决。第一轮——林代尔胜。
Fast forward about 10 years when another state legislator got, according to Linndalers, a burr in his ass about the village, although, he wouldn't describe it that way. His name's Tom Patton. He used to be a senator. Now he's in the House. And he approached the Linndale problem from another direction. And what he did was pretty ingenious.
快进到大约10年后，另一位州立法者，据林代尔人所说，对这个村庄也产生了“心病”，尽管他不会那样描述。他的名字叫汤姆·巴顿（Tom Patton）。他以前是参议员。现在在众议院。他从另一个方向处理林代尔问题。他所做的事情非常天才。
I came up with the idea because I've put in a bill that said, if you have less than 150 people, you can't have a Mayor's Court.
我想到了这个主意，因为我提出了一项法案，规定如果你的城镇人口少于150人，你就不能设立镇长法庭。
At that time, Linndale was reported to have 117 residents. It's ingenious because that little local village court in Linndale is how the village was able to keep all the money it generated from the tickets. Whatever court a speeding case is heard in, the fines and other costs stay in that court. Without its Mayor's Court, all the fines would be processed somewhere else, and Linndale would only get a fraction or nothing at all. It was, essentially, rerouting the plumbing through which all the ticket money flowed.
当时，据报道林代尔有117名居民。这很天才，因为林代尔那个小小的当地村镇法庭正是村庄能够保留从罚单中产生的所有资金的方式。无论超速案件在哪个法庭审理，罚款和其他费用都留在该法庭。没有了镇长法庭，所有罚款都会在其他地方处理，而林代尔只能得到一小部分或根本什么也得不到。这本质上是在重新路由所有罚单资金流向的管道。
Now, Tom Patton, like Ed Kasputis before him, claims his bill wasn't solely about Linndale. He says he's against Mayor's Courts in general. But then, after he wrote his bill saying that, if your village has fewer than 150 people, you can't have a Mayor's Court, the census came out saying that Linndale didn't have 117 residents. It had 179 residents.
现在，汤姆·巴顿，像之前的埃德·卡斯普蒂斯一样，声称他的法案不仅仅是为了针对林代尔。他说他反对一般的镇长法庭。但随后，在他写下“如果你的村庄少于150人，你就不能设立镇长法庭”的法案后，人口普查结果出来显示林代尔并没有117名居民。它有179名居民。
So we simply crossed out 150 on the bill and we made it 200.
所以我们只是把法案上的150划掉，改成了200。
The bill passed in 2012 and Linndale police were still allowed to ticket on 71. They just weren't keeping as much of the proceeds now, with no Mayor's Court. I read one report that said, at this point, income from the tickets dropped to a little more than 1% of what it had been. Jobs went away, the court clerk for one. There's no court anymore.
该法案在2012年通过，林代尔警察仍然被允许在71号公路上开罚单。只是现在没有了镇长法庭，他们留下的收益没那么多了。我读到的一份报告显示，此时，罚单收入降到了之前的1%多一点。工作岗位减少了，例如法庭书记员。没有法庭了。
Steve Pokrandt remembers those days pretty well. We talked on his back porch in Linndale. Sort of a tiki theme back there. Steve was the maintenance man for the village when the Mayor's Court went away.
史蒂夫·波克兰特（Steve Pokrandt）对那些日子记忆犹新。我们在林代尔他的后门廊上谈话。那里有点提基（tiki）主题。当镇长法庭消失时，史蒂夫是村里的维护员。
They cut everyone's pay. Minimum wage is what they cut me down to. The bank account was draining because nothing's coming in. Health care was eliminated for the employees that used to receive it.
他们削减了每个人的工资。他们把我的工资降到了最低工资标准。银行账户在流血，因为没钱进账。员工们以前享受的医疗福利被取消了。
And what was it like in the town during that time? Did it feel less--
那段时期镇上的生活怎么样？感觉有没有——
Not happy. It was not happy. Sit around the office and, oh, just, oh. We would say, well, what happens to a government if it runs out of money? Does it just fold up? And what about the trash? Who takes care of the people? There's rumors. You'd hear like, well, if that happens, the state will take us over. And nobody really knew at the time.
不开心。很不开心。坐在办公室里，噢，就是，噢。我们会说，好吧，如果一个政府没钱了会怎么样？它会倒闭吗？还有垃圾怎么办？谁来照顾大家？有谣言说，好吧，如果发生那种情况，州政府会接管我们。当时没人真的知道。
If you're wondering what Linndale was spending all its money on, here's a really basic breakdown. At this point, the total budget was about $1.2 million, with most of it from speeding tickets and a little from property and income taxes-- things like that. About 60% of that went to the security of persons and property, which mostly means the police department and a little bit to Cleveland Fire and EMS. The average for other villages in the county is 37%. Another quarter of Linndale's budget went to government salaries-- the mayor, treasurer, a teeny bit for the village counselors.
如果你想知道林代尔把所有的钱都花在什么地方，这里有一个非常基础的细分。此时，总预算约为120万美元，其中大部分来自超速罚单，一小部分来自房产税和所得税——诸如此类。大约60%用于人员和财产安全，这主要是指警察局，还有一小部分给克利夫兰消防和紧急医疗服务。县里其他村庄的平均值是37%。林代尔预算的另外四分之一用于政府工资——镇长、财务主管，还有一点点给村议员。
If you're keeping track, that's almost everything. Every other category is much less. Utility services-- that's trash pick-up and stuff-- was half of 1%. Again, this was all in the Mayor's Court days. The police expenses and government salaries have dropped a lot since then. Also, Linndale spent $100,000 appealing the law that Representative Patton wrote. And this time, they lost that appeal. So round 2-- the state of Ohio. And Tom Patton was the captain of that team.
如果你在做记录，那差不多就是全部了。其他每个类别的支出都少得多。公用事业服务——那是垃圾回收之类的——占了0.5%。再次强调，这都是在镇长法庭时代。从那以后，警察支出和政府工资大幅下降。此外，林代尔花了10万美元上诉众议员巴顿撰写的法律。而这一次，他们输掉了上诉。所以第二轮——俄亥俄州政府胜。汤姆·巴顿是那支队伍的队长。
And all hail the conquering hero. People thought-- I mean, that's not--
所有人都向凯旋的英雄致敬。人们以为——我是说，那不是——
All hail what?
向谁致敬？
The conquering hero.
凯旋的英雄。
That was you?
那是你？
I think the way that people responded to it-- there was also, oh, thank God you got rid of Linndale.
我想人们对它的反应——也有人说，哦，谢天谢地，你除掉了林代尔。
I mean, I get what you're saying that, on its face, it seems cynical to fund your town largely on the backs of speeding motorists. And something just feels unscrupulous about that. But isn't it equally cynical and unscrupulous to devise legislation that would apply to the whole state when you pretty much have this one community in mind over time?
我是说，我明白你的意思，表面上看，主要靠超速司机来资助你的城镇似乎很狡诈。而且这确实让人感觉不正当。但难道为了针对这个社区，制定适用于整个州的立法，不也同样狡诈和不正当吗？
No, it's not a question of targeting. This happens to be something that-- they're in the media a lot. They get coverage a lot. So it's kind of put in our face. I actually had reporters come and say, now they're doing this. What's your next move?
不，这不是针对的问题。这碰巧是——他们经常出现在媒体上。他们经常得到报道。所以这有点像是摆在我们面前。实际上有记者来问，现在他们正在做这个。你的下一步是什么？
Which is the question I have, too.
这也是我的问题。
And I said, well, it's not a question of making moves.
我说，好吧，这不是采取什么行动的问题。
Representative Patton didn't simply want Linndale to stop ticketing people. He thinks the village shouldn't exist, that it should merge with Cleveland or with another suburb nearby. He actually doesn't think any village as small as Linndale should exist. And now he had driven the village one step closer to extinction.
众议员巴顿不仅仅想让林代尔停止给人开罚单。他认为这个村庄不应该存在，它应该与克利夫兰或其他附近的郊区合并。他其实认为任何像林代尔这么小的村庄都不应该存在。而现在，他已将这个村庄推向了灭绝边缘。
But the village was only in the red for about six months, because right around this time, there was a change in administration. A new mayor, Ashlee McLaughlin. And she had an ingenious idea, too. The village council had already been discussing it. There's this one intersection in town by the police station. It's where Memphis Avenue meets Avenue of Peace. And Memphis Avenue is really well-trafficked. In fact, people go barreling down that street at speeds way above the 25 mile an hour limit. Mayor McLaughlin says the village wanted to enforce traffic laws there anyway. And they could do it in a way that they didn't even have to pull people over.
但村庄只亏损了大约六个月，因为就在这个时候，政府换届了。新任镇长阿什莉·麦克劳克林（Ashlee McLaughlin）。她也有一个天才的主意。村委会已经在讨论它了。镇上警察局旁边有一个路口。那是孟菲斯大道（Memphis Avenue）与和平大道（Avenue of Peace）交汇的地方。孟菲斯大道车流量非常大。事实上，人们在街上狂奔的速度远远超过25英里的限速。麦克劳克林镇长说，村庄无论如何都想在那里执行交通法规。而且他们可以不用把人拦下来的方式来做到。
And where is the camera?
相机在哪里？
There's one right there.
就在那儿有一个。
OK. Two cameras--
好的。两台相机——
That lovely green pole that doesn't--
那根可爱的绿色杆子，它并没有——
Mayor McLaughlin had two speed-limit cameras installed on that corner-- one on each side of the road. These things are all over the place now. You've seen them. If you're speeding, they take a picture of your car and send you a ticket in the mail within a month. And most importantly, it's a civil infraction, not a criminal one, so it doesn't have to be processed through a court.
麦克劳克林镇长在那个路口安装了两台限速摄像机——路的两侧各一台。这些东西现在随处可见。你们见过它们。如果你超速，它们会拍下你的车，并在一个月内把罚单寄给你。最重要的是，这是一项民事违章，不是刑事违章，所以不需要通过法庭处理。
OK. And there's a sign right next to it that says "traffic laws, photo enforced."
好的。旁边有一个标志写着“交通法规，照片执法”。
It says, "speed limit 25-- photo enforced."
它写着，“限速25——照片执法”。
These two cameras are set to go off if you're driving 11 miles an hour or more over the limit. And so many cars go that fast on Memphis Avenue that Linndale is pulling in more money from the cameras than it did on the highway. Mayor McLaughlin also told me that there used to be four accidents a year at that corner, but since the cameras went up in 2013, there have been zero.
这两台摄像机设置在如果你超速11英里或以上时触发。在孟菲斯大道上以那个速度行驶的车辆太多了，林代尔从摄像机那里收到的钱比在高速公路上还要多。麦克劳克林镇长还告诉我，那个路口以前每年有四起事故，但自从2013年安装摄像机以来，事故数为零。
Now, as it happens, there are a few folks in the state legislature who just hate traffic cameras in general. And by mere coincidence, not long after Linndale put up its traffic cameras, another bill passed that said, among other things, traffic cameras could only be used in Ohio if a police officer was, quote, "present at the location of the device." And when this bill went through, almost half the communities in Ohio that had been using traffic cameras said they were going to stop using them. Columbus, Dayton, Springfield, West Carrollton. And certainly no places started using them.
现在，巧合的是，州立法机构里有几个人非常讨厌一般的交通摄像机。而就在林代尔装上摄像机后不久，又有一项法案通过了，其中规定，俄亥俄州只有在警察，引述，“出现在设备所在位置”时，才能使用交通摄像机。当这项法案通过时，俄亥俄州近一半使用交通摄像机的社区表示他们将停止使用。哥伦布、代顿、斯普林菲尔德、西卡罗尔顿。而且当然没有任何地方开始使用它们。
You want to guess who did keep their traffic camera running with an officer stationed by it?
你想猜猜是谁保留了他们的交通摄像机，并让警察驻守在旁边吗？
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
Officer?
警官？
Hey, how you doing, mam?
嘿，你好吗，女士？
Hi.
你好。
For a while, Linndale just parked an unmarked cruiser with an officer in it by the cameras. But then they decided, that's nuts. We can't do that, just to have a guy there in a car all day. No. Instead, they built a hut. I call it a hut.
有一段时间，林代尔只是把一辆没有标记的巡逻车停在摄像机旁边，里面坐着一名警官。但后来他们觉得，这太疯狂了。我们不能那样做，整天让一个人坐在车里。不。相反，他们建了一个小屋。我称之为小屋。
Bernie Mac is on TV.
电视上正在播伯尼·麦（Bernie Mac）。
It's got a TV, a combination DVD/VCR machine, boombox, microwave--
里面有一台电视，一台DVD/录像机组合，音响，微波炉——
Oh. There is a dorm fridge. Oh, wow.
噢。还有一个宿舍用的冰箱。哇。
And yes, a split-screen security monitor so they can keep tabs on what's happening on the roadway. Oh. And there's a window through which you can see the cameras. Ralph Moncrief was the traffic enforcement officer on duty that day. He's a mixed martial artist. Sometimes, he brings a weight bench to his shift and trains outside the hut for his tournaments. Mayor McLaughlin explained this to me while we were sitting in the village hall with Linndale's law director, Richard Neff.
是的，还有一个分屏监控显示器，这样他们可以随时关注路面上发生的事情。哦。还有一个窗口，通过它可以看摄像机。拉尔夫·蒙克里夫（Ralph Moncrief）是那天值班的交通执法警官。他是一名混合武术家。有时，他会在换班时带一张举重凳，在小屋外面训练比赛。麦克劳克林镇长在村政厅和林代尔法律主管理查德·内夫（Richard Neff）一起坐着时向我解释了这一点。
So Linndale is paying an officer to go down there and work out for however many hours.
所以林代尔正在付钱让一名警官去那里锻炼几个小时。
We're paying him to monitor the cameras.
我们付钱让他监控摄像机。
But what does that mean, monitoring the cameras?
但这算什么，监控摄像机？
He has to be present, and he has to be within physical eyeline of the cameras.
他必须在场，而且他必须在摄像机的物理视线范围内。
For wh-- for what? Is he making sure they're on?
为了什——为了什么？他在确认它们开着吗？
Ask the legislature. They're the ones that decided that was the requirement.
问立法机构。是他们决定那是必要条件的。
If they want officers there, fine. I think we just became a little bit more famous because we're one of the few people that complied with this.
如果他们想要警察在那里，行。我想我们变得更出名了，因为我们是少数遵守这一规定的人之一。
And you're Linndale-- not to put too fine a point on it.
而且你们是林代尔——为了不把话说得太绝对。
Well, you know, we want to comply.
好吧，你知道，我们想要合规。
Does it feel like, Alaska has oil. Pennsylvania has natural gas. Linndale has people going more than 25 miles an hour?
有没有一种感觉，阿拉斯加有石油。宾夕法尼亚有天然气。林代尔有车速超过25英里的人？
That's a very funny way to state that. No, I don't look at the criminals as a natural resource.
这是个很有趣的表达方式。不，我不把罪犯视为自然资源。
No?
不是吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不这么看。
I mean, they're going to be there.
我是说，他们会一直待在那里。
Not if they stop speeding.
如果他们不超速，就不会了。
But if they stop speeding, no money.
但如果他们不超速，就没有钱了。
We'll be OK.
我们会没事的。
If they stop speeding, it's safer. That's our goal.
如果他们不超速，更安全。那是我们的目标。
Right.
对。
That's the whole goal?
这就是全部目标？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes. Yes!
是。是的！
After I got back home from Cleveland, the Ohio State Supreme Court ruled that the law saying an officer must be present at the traffic cameras was unconstitutional, that it violated the same provision as before with Ed Kasputis' bill.
在我从克利夫兰回家后，俄亥俄州最高法院裁定，要求交通摄像机必须有警察在场的法律违宪，它违反了之前埃德·卡斯普蒂斯法案中相同的规定。
Representative Patton was disappointed, partly because the decision could compromise this whole new round of bills he has drafted. One says you can't use traffic cameras if your community takes in more than 30% of its money every year from camera tickets. Another says the number of camera tickets a community issues can't be more than twice the population of that place. And you can't issue any tickets at all if your town has fewer than 200 people. He still insists that the bills are not specifically targeting Linndale. Linndalers don't buy it.
巴顿众议员感到失望，部分原因是这项决定可能会损害他起草的整整一轮新法案。其中一项规定，如果你的社区每年收入中超过30%来自摄像机罚单，你就不能使用交通摄像机。另一项规定，社区发出的摄像机罚单数量不能超过该地人口的两倍。而且如果你的城镇人口少于200人，你根本不能发出任何罚单。他仍然坚称这些法案并没有特别针对林代尔。林代尔人并不买账。
Mayor McLaughlin says, if the ticketing in Linndale was just to make money, they'd put cameras up all over the village. Representative Patton doesn't buy it.
麦克劳克林镇长说，如果林代尔开罚单只是为了赚钱，他们会把摄像机装满整个村庄。巴顿众议员并不买账。
And in both cases, how could you buy it? It seems obvious what each side is up to, and yet neither will acknowledge it, even though both sides are well within their rights to be doing what they're doing. Both are playing by the rules, by the letter of the law. And yet, at the same time, in both cases, what they're doing just seems a little underhanded somehow. So it's hard to come down on one side or the other. Although, as with all my favorite comedies, it's fun to watch the little mouse outsmart the cat over and over again.
在这两种情况下，你怎么能买账呢？双方在干什么似乎显而易见，然而谁也不肯承认，尽管双方做这些事都在各自的权利范围内。双方都在按规则出牌，按法律的字面意思行事。然而同时，在这两种情况下，他们所做的事情看起来都有点狡诈。所以很难站在哪一边。不过，就像我所有最喜欢的喜剧一样，看着这只小老鼠一遍又一遍地智胜这只大猫，还是很有趣的。
Sean Cole-- he's one of the producers of our show. Coming up, a transportation system that is designed to keep you waiting and to send you on routes far out of your way, which is exactly as unfun as it sounds. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
肖恩·科尔——他是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，一个设计旨在让你等待并把你带到偏离路线很远的运输系统，这听起来和事实一样一点也不好玩。稍后芝加哥公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Expect Delays-- stories of trying to get from one place to another.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“预期延误”——关于尝试从一个地方到另一个地方的故事。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Asleep at the Wheel.
我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“瞌睡虫在方向盘前”。
So in the first half of today's program, we heard about people speeding down a stretch of road in Ohio faster than the speed limit. Now in this act, we head to a different continent and another stretch of road and another group of motorists trying to get from here to there, but not speeding at all. Kind of the opposite, in fact. Here's Stephanie Foo.
在今天节目的上半部分，我们听到了人们在俄亥俄州的一段路上以超过限速的速度飞驰。现在在这一幕中，我们前往另一个大洲、另一段道路和另一群试图从这儿到那儿、但完全没有超速的司机。事实上，恰恰相反。这是斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）。
Louisa Lim was reporting for the BBC in China. And in September 2004, she was heading through the province of Ningxia to interview a mayor. She was with her producer, her cameraman, a driver, and her minder.
路易莎·林（Louisa Lim）曾为英国广播公司在中国报道。2004年9月，她正前往宁夏省采访一位镇长。她和她的制作人、摄像师、司机以及监管人员在一起。
At that time, within China, you had to travel everywhere with a government official, like a minder, watching you. So we were also traveling with this minder from the local government, who inexplicably had brought his wife, as well. So we were a little bit confused about what purpose she was actually playing, but we figured she just kind of wanted a trip. And he was a very interesting character. He was very fiery-natured.
当时在中国，你必须和政府官员一起旅行，比如一个监管人员，监视你。所以我们当时也和这位来自地方政府的监管人员一起旅行，莫名其妙地他还带了他的妻子。所以我们对她究竟起什么作用感到有点困惑，但我们觉得她可能只是想出来旅游。他是一个非常有趣的人物。他脾气非常火爆。
Which is her polite way of saying he kept getting in fights with all of the officials he'd introduced them to. Anyway, so there's five people and Louisa-- a whole entourage. And they're all crammed into this tiny van. People in China call them bread vans because they're white and boxy like a loaf of bread. It's like a Chinese Wes Anderson film, complete with curmudgeonly Chinese Bill Murray.
这是她委婉的说法，意思是他在向他们介绍的所有官员面前一直发生冲突。总之，有五个人和路易莎——一个完整的随行人员。他们都挤在这辆小面包车里。中国人都称它们为“面包车”，因为它们是白色的，像面包一样方方正正。这就像一部中国版韦斯·安德森（Wes Anderson）电影，配上一个脾气古怪的中国版比尔·默瑞（Bill Murray）。
And to begin with, it was quite nice-- bucolic landscapes and farmers pitching hay, and hills stretching into the distance. And then suddenly, we hit just this massive traffic jam. By then, it was relatively late. It was already like 10:00 at night. And when we looked in the distance, all we could see was the little red dots, rear lights of the cars lining up in front of us, just as far as the eye could see. Nothing was moving. It was just total gridlock.
起初，还挺不错的——田园风光，农民在翻晒干草，山丘延伸到远方。然后突然，我们遇到了大堵车。那时候已经比较晚了。已经是晚上10点了。当我们向远处望去，看到的只有前方排成一列的小红点，汽车的尾灯，一眼望不到头。没有东西在动。简直就是彻底的瘫痪。
Louisa's minder went and talked to some other people in the jam and learned that there was a massive road repair, which had narrowed the highway to one lane. A bunch of trucks tried to cut the line and jam themselves through the narrow opening, which just created an impassable mess of tiny traffic jams and accidents. Her minder, for once, hadn't picked a fight with anyone. He didn't even seem particularly frustrated. It was weird.
路易莎的监管人员去和堵车里的其他人交谈，了解到是因为大规模的道路维修，将公路缩小到了一条车道。一群卡车试图插队，挤进那个狭窄的开口，这造成了一团混乱，充满了细小的堵车和事故。她的监管人员，破天荒地没和任何人打架。他看起来甚至没觉得特别沮丧。真奇怪。
He was just completely resigned. He just kind of shrugged his shoulders and said, no. We're not going anywhere. There's no way out. We'll just have to spend the night here. And he just seemed fine with this idea. And I was definitely not fine with the idea of sleeping in this little bread van with all these people in the middle of nowhere all night long. And I was also really worried. I remember, because earlier that week, we'd read an article in the office about people who'd been stuck in a traffic jam for five days and five nights.
他彻底顺从了。他只是耸了耸肩说，不。我们哪儿也去不了。没路可走了。我们只能在这儿过夜了。他似乎对这个想法很满意。我肯定对整晚和这些人挤在这辆小面包车里过夜的想法一点也不满意。我当时还真的很担心。我记得，因为那一周早些时候，我们在办公室读过一篇关于人们被堵在路上五天五夜的文章。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
So we were just imagining that could be us.
所以我们当时想象那可能就是我们。
In fact, traffic jams that last more than a couple days happen so often in China that there was a parody pop song detailing what you should always keep in your car, just in case. There was an epic jam in 2010 that made international news, where a highway was backed up for more than 10 days and stretched 74 miles.
事实上，持续超过几天的交通堵塞在中国经常发生，以至于有一首恶搞流行歌曲详细说明了你应该在车里准备什么，以防万一。2010年发生了一次国际新闻中的史诗级大堵车，一条高速公路堵了超过10天，绵延74英里。
There are a few reasons why this happens. A huge increase in the number of cars on the road in recent years, lots of newer drivers with little experience, badly maintained roads, and poor civic planning.
造成这种情况的原因有几个。近年来路上汽车数量急剧增加，许多缺乏经验的新手司机，维护不善的道路，以及糟糕的城市规划。
I know that it's become a thing that if you get stuck in traffic, local villages start coming out and selling you bottles of water and cooking for you and setting up their own businesses. But we were really in the middle of nowhere. There was no one around us. We didn't have anything. We had a few bottles of water, but we didn't have any food or anything else. Certainly not for five days and five nights. That's one of the reasons why we were worried, but mainly, I was worried because I was a bit of a control freak and I was like, I cannot spend the night here. I'm not going to waste my time and mess up all my schedules.
我知道如果被堵在路上，当地村民会出来卖瓶装水并为你做饭，建立他们自己的生意，这已经成了常态。但我们当时真的在荒郊野外。周围一个人也没有。我们什么也没有。我们有几瓶水，但我们没有食物或其他任何东西。当然不可能应付五天五夜。那是我们担心的原因之一，但主要是因为我有点控制狂，我当时想，我不能在这儿过夜。我不想浪费时间并打乱我所有的行程。
And then, I think, by hour three, we were getting out and talking to people. And it was quite interesting because all around us there were trucks. It was a big truck route. And in the truck behind us, there were six men who were crammed into that cabin and they were playing cards. And they were just totally unbothered by the situation. They didn't seem the slightest bit worried at all. And when I said to them, aren't you worried? They went, no, no, no. It's fine. It happens all the time. One of them told us that he'd been stuck for seven days and seven nights in a row before.
然后，我想，到了第三个小时，我们下车和人聊天。这很有趣，因为周围都是卡车。这是一条大卡车路线。在我们身后的卡车里，有六个男人挤在驾驶室里，他们正在打牌。他们对这种情况完全没受影响。他们看起来一点也不担心。当我问他们，你们不担心吗？他们说，不，不，不。没关系。这经常发生。其中一个人告诉我们他曾经连续七天七夜被堵在那里。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Right. One of them said he spent four nights a month sleeping in traffic jams because it was just so common.
对。其中一个人说他每个月有四天晚上是在堵车中睡觉的，因为这太常见了。
They managed to get the flow of traffic going again within 12 hours, but something that really stuck with Louisa was the look all the other truck drivers gave her.
他们在12小时内设法恢复了交通流，但有一件事真正让路易莎记忆深刻，那就是所有其他卡车司机看她的眼神。
I think they just thought that we were-- that I, in particular, was just really over the top. They were just like, what are you fussing about? That's just the way that it is.
我想他们只是认为我们——特别是我想，只是反应过度了。他们就像是，你在大惊小怪什么？事情就是这样。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
And traffic jams are so common, I don't get upset over this.
堵车太常见了，我不为这个生气。
This is Liu Zefeng. He's 47 years old. He's been a trucker in China for about 18 years now. He was not in Louisa's traffic jam, but he's been in plenty of jams like it. On every 11-day haul he takes, he says he'll get stuck at least a couple times overnight, midnight to morning, which, amazingly, doesn't bother him.
这是刘泽丰。他47岁。在中国当卡车司机大约18年了。他当时不在路易莎那个堵车现场，但他经历过无数次类似的堵车。在他执行的每一次11天行程中，他说他至少会几次被堵在夜里，从午夜到清晨，令人惊奇的是，这对他没有影响。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
In fact, we're kind of happy about it, otherwise we'll be driving nonstop. It's very tiring, so the traffic jam provides time for rest.
其实我们挺高兴的，要不然一直开，累得慌，堵车正好休息。
This is crazy to me because if I was stuck in a traffic jam for three days, I would lose my mind I'd be so stressed out.
这对我来说太疯狂了，因为如果我被堵在路上三天，我会疯掉的，我会压力很大。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
Mainly, you really have to plan ahead and think ahead. Always have enough fuel in the truck, food, some snacks. And always keep hot water in the truck to make instant noodle. We will bring bread. We will bring instant noodles. We will bring some cake. And that's about it.
主要就是提前规划好，多带油、多带吃的、带点零食。车里肯定要备开水泡方便面。带馒头、带方便面、带点蛋糕，就这些。
That's a lot of carbs.
那碳水化合物含量很高啊。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
No vegetables. We can't think about healthy or not healthy in those moments.
没菜，那种情况下顾不上健不健康。
Chinese truckers are so used to these jams that Liu told me that, late in the evening, everyone starts driving more slowly. And after midnight, when traffic gets slow enough, truck drivers will turn their vehicles off and go to sleep right there in the middle of the highway. And even if the road clears ahead of them, they won't inch forward. They'll just wait until morning to wake up, start their cars, and get going again.
中国卡车司机太习惯这些堵车了，刘告诉我，深夜里，每个人开始开得更慢。而在午夜之后，当交通变得足够缓慢时，卡车司机就会关掉引擎，就在高速公路中间睡着了。即使前面的路空了，他们也不会向前挪动。他们会一直等到早上醒来，启动车辆，再次上路。
Liu's worst jam was during a 2008 ice storm, where the road became too slippery to drive on. He and all the other truck drivers went to sleep like they always do, figuring it'd be over in a few hours. But in the morning, it was still jammed.
刘经历过最糟糕的一次堵车是在2008年的冰雪灾害期间，道路变得太滑，无法行驶。他和所有其他卡车司机像往常一样睡觉，以为几个小时就会过去。但在早上，依然堵着。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
We start getting out of our trucks and start comparing what we were all hauling. So we were hauling oranges. Other trucks were hauling watermelons, bananas. So we naturally started to trade each other's goods to eat.
都下车交换自己带的东西吃，我们拉的是橘子。有的卡车拉西瓜、香蕉。大家自然而然就开始交换货吃了。
Their employers actually give them a case to keep or trade. Liu was stuck there for a total of three days and three nights. There are videos online of people getting out of their cars during large traffic jams. And they get creative to entertain themselves. They play volleyball, barbecue, even square dance. I was excited to discover how Liu passed the time.
他们的雇主实际上给了他们一箱东西保留或交换。刘总共被堵在那里三天三夜。网上有视频显示人们在大型堵车期间下车。他们通过创意娱乐自己。他们打排球、烧烤，甚至跳广场舞。我很高兴发现刘是怎么打发时间的。
What do you do for fun for three days?
你三天怎么消遣？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
Nothing special. We would just sleep and get up and see how the traffic's going and we will fall back to sleep and come back up.
没什么特殊的。就是睡觉，醒了看看交通情况，睡醒了再看看，接着睡。
You just sleep for three days straight?
你就整整睡了三天？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
Certainly, you must do other things for three days.
肯定还要做点别的，待三天。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
No.
没有。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
When nearby residents come and give or start to sell eggs or hot water or instant noodle, we got up and see if there's anything we want. If there's nothing, we just go back to bed. Just shut that door and go to sleep.
附近居民过来给点或者卖点鸡蛋、开水、方便面，就看看要不要。没啥事就接着睡觉，门一关就睡觉。
Do you have conversations with the other truck drivers to get to know them?
你会和其他卡车司机聊天了解他们吗？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[中文语音]
No. They also were sleeping in their own trucks.
没，他们也都在各自车上睡觉。
Normally, if you're on your way somewhere and there's a delay, you can choose to fight back, search for an alternate route, call customer service to book a different flight, ditch your bike and rent a car. But sometimes there's no other option. You've got no choice but to surrender and live in the moment of your delay, like Liu does. Relax. Kick back. Sleep it off.
通常，如果你在去某个地方的路上遇到了延误，你可以选择反抗、寻找替代路线、给客户服务打电话预订不同的航班、扔掉自行车租辆车。但有时别无选择。你只能投降，活在延误的那一刻，就像刘一样。放松。休息。睡一觉。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our show.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, The Longest Distance Between Two Points.
第三幕，两点之间最长的距离。
In New York City, most of the subways are not accessible. Almost 80% don't have elevators. So disabled New Yorkers and some elderly New Yorkers use a system called Access-A-Ride. Cities all over the country have their own versions. In New York City, the way it works is that you call the day before you need to go somewhere. You have to call by 5:00 PM to schedule your trip. They assign you a pickup time. Often, it's as much as two hours before the time you need to get to where you're going.
在纽约市，大多数地铁都不方便。近80%没有电梯。所以残障纽约客和一些老年纽约客使用一种叫做Access-A-Ride的服务系统。全国各地的城市都有自己的版本。在纽约，它的运作方式是你需要在出发的前一天预约行程。你必须在下午5点前打电话预约你的行程。他们会为你分配一个接送时间。通常，这甚至会比你需要到达目的地的时间早两个小时。
What this means is that, if you're leading a normal, adult life and your plans change in any way on the day of the ride, you're stuck. You can't do anything. You can't get a different time. If you cancel, you have to explain why. Too many cancellations within a certain period, and they can cut you off. And that is the service when it runs the way that it's supposed to. Delays and waits are literally built into it. Like, that's the premise.
这意味着，如果你过着正常的成年人生活，并且在出发当天你的计划有任何变动，你就被困住了。你什么也做不了。你无法调整时间。如果你取消，你必须解释原因。在一定时期内取消次数过多，他们就会把你关掉。而且这还是在该服务正常运行时的情况。延误和等待从字面上讲就是其中的一部分。就像，这就是前提。
Britney Wilson uses the service every day.
布兰妮·威尔逊（Britney Wilson）每天都在使用这个服务。
I've been using Access-A-Ride since I was 11 years old, around the age many New York City kids begin riding public transportation by themselves. I'm a black woman with Cerebral Palsy. There are many different forms and degrees of CP, but mine particularly affects my lower body. I wear leg braces and walk with crutches. Access-A-Ride is notorious among the people who rely on it for being inefficient and unreliable. People call it Stress-A-Ride.
我从11岁起就开始使用Access-A-Ride了，那时候很多纽约孩子开始自己乘坐公共交通。我是一个患有脑瘫的黑人女性。脑瘫有很多不同的形式和程度，但我的主要影响我的下肢。我戴着腿部矫形器，拄着拐杖走路。Access-A-Ride在依赖它的人群中以效率低下和不可靠而闻名。人们称它为“压力骑行”（Stress-A-Ride）。
I've been fighting this system since I was a kid. At first, I protested the service's problems in true millennial fashion. I complained to family, friends, and social media followers, wrote blog posts, and started change.org petitions. Then I went to law school to gain the knowledge and skills necessary to fight on behalf of myself and others. I graduated two years ago from the University of Pennsylvania Law School. Now I'm back home in Brooklyn, practicing civil rights law, and I'm back on Access-A-Ride. I take it to and from work every day.
从还是个孩子起，我就一直在与这个系统做斗争。起初，我以真正的千禧一代方式抗议该服务的问题。我向家人、朋友和社交媒体粉丝抱怨，写博客文章，并发起change.org请愿。然后我去读了法学院，以获得为自己和他人争取权益所需的知识和技能。两年前，我从宾夕法尼亚大学法学院毕业。现在我回到了布鲁克林的家中，从事民权法律工作，我又回到了Access-A-Ride。我每天乘它上下班。
I've spoken at transportation board meetings and appeared on local news talking about changes that need to be made to the system. And I'm not shy about filing formal complaints. Something happens every two months or so the calls for it. One of my biggest problems with Access-A-Ride is the wait. You tell Access-A-Ride when you need to be somewhere, and they give you a pickup time. But the pickup times are aspirational at best. They've actually started calling them Promised Times. But it seems like a promise made with their fingers crossed behind their backs. Access-A-Ride is considered to be on time if it's not more than 30 minutes late, but it's common for it to take over an hour. You're supposed to wait outside at your pickup time, no matter the weather. Sometimes riders just don't get picked up at all.
我在交通董事会会议上发言，并出现在当地新闻节目中，谈论系统需要做出的改变。对于提交正式投诉，我从不害羞。每隔两个月左右就会发生一些事情，促使我这样做。我对Access-A-Ride最大的不满之一就是等待时间。你告诉Access-A-Ride你需要去哪里，他们给你一个接送时间。但这些接送时间充其量只是期望值。他们实际上已经开始称它们为“承诺时间”。但这看起来就像是手指交叉背在身后做出的承诺。Access-A-Ride被认为准时，如果它迟到不超过30分钟，但超过一个小时的情况很常见。无论天气如何，你都应该在接送时间在外面等候。有时乘客甚至根本就不会被接走。
Although we riders can get stuck waiting for hours, drivers only have to give us a five-minute grace period if we're not outside when they arrive. They're encouraged to call us if they don't see us, but technically, those calls are courtesies, not requirements. One winter evening, my driver stopped to pick up a passenger who wasn't outside when we pulled up. After a few minutes, a black woman who was probably in our 70s exited a nearby McDonald's, rushing and pushing a walker in front of her.
尽管我们乘客会被困住等待数小时，但司机只有在我们到达时不在外面时，才需要给我们五分钟的宽限期。如果他们没看见我们，他们被鼓励给我们打电话，但从技术上讲，这些电话是礼貌性的，而不是强制性的。一个冬天的傍晚，我的司机停下来去接一位没在车外的乘客。几分钟后，一位大概70多岁的黑人女性从附近的麦当劳走了出来，她很匆忙，推着助行器。
There were three black garbage bags resting on her walker seat. As the driver got off the bus to let the lift down, he yelled, you're lucky I didn't leave you. It's been more than five minutes. Five minutes, she asked. I've been waiting for this ride for over three hours. The people in the McDonald's let me sit down and wait inside, and I didn't see you when you first pulled up. You're over the bag limit, the driver said. The limit is two. You have three. That's what's wrong with Access-A-Ride people. You take advantage. You're spoiled and entitled.
她的助行器座位上有三个黑色垃圾袋。当司机下车放下升降梯时，他吼道：“你真幸运我没走。已经超过五分钟了。”“五分钟？”她问道。“我等这趟车等了三个多小时了。麦当劳里的人让我进去坐着等，你刚来的时候我没看见。”“你的行李超标了，”司机说。“限制是两个。你有三个。这就是Access-A-Ride人毛病所在。你们占便宜。你们被宠坏了，自以为是。”
I've come across this attitude a lot. We should be happy we have this service, no matter how dysfunctional it is or what we have to put up with in the process. We should be happy we have anything at all. Poor people and people of color are often accused of being entitled, but so are people with disabilities. And many people who use Access-A-Ride are all three.
我经常遇到这种态度。无论它多么功能失调或在此过程中我们必须忍受什么，我们都应该为拥有这项服务感到高兴。我们应该为拥有它感到高兴。贫困人口和有色人种经常被指责为“享有特权”，但残疾人也被如此指责。而许多使用Access-A-Ride的人三者兼有。
The woman was outraged. She told the driver he didn't even have to help her with her bags. She was handling them herself. She explained that she only got to go grocery shopping once in a while, so she crammed as many grocery bags as she could into the garbage bags, trying her best not to violate the bag limit. Do you have a mother, she asked the driver. Would you want someone treating her this way when she gets old?
那位女性非常愤怒。她告诉司机他甚至不必帮她拿行李。她自己可以处理。她解释说，她只是偶尔能去买一次菜，所以她尽力把尽可能多的购物袋塞进垃圾袋里，试图不违反行李限制。“你有母亲吗？”她问司机。“当她变老时，你愿意有人这样对待她吗？”
The thing I complain the most about is the routes. Access-A-Ride drivers have to follow predetermined routes, which are created each day based on who's riding and where they're going. But the routes don't make any sense. Often, half of my ride is spent going in the opposite direction of my destination. I only work 8 miles away, maybe a 45-minute drive, but on average, it takes me 2 hours each way to go between my home and my office.
我抱怨最多的是路线。Access-A-Ride司机必须遵循预定的路线，这些路线是根据谁在乘车以及他们要去哪里每天创建的。但路线完全不合理。通常，我一半的行程都是在朝着与目的地相反的方向走。我上班只有8英里远，可能只需要45分钟车程，但平均而言，往返于我的家和办公室之间需要2个小时。
Many drivers have openly agreed with me about changes that need to be made to the service. On rides, we bond over everything from the struggle of being a Knicks fan to the struggle of being a pawn in the Access-A-Ride system. It's a stressful job, and they don't like having to drive from Brooklyn to the Bronx and back again in no logical order any more than passengers like having to experience it.
许多司机公开同意我关于服务需要改进的意见。在旅途中，我们从作为尼克斯队（Knicks）球迷的挣扎到作为Access-A-Ride系统中棋子的挣扎，什么都聊。这是一份压力很大的工作，他们不像乘客喜欢体验那样，喜欢被迫在没有任何逻辑顺序的情况下往返于布鲁克林和布朗克斯之间。
Sometimes I complain to drivers I like about drivers I don't. One of my favorite drivers told me that drivers did the same thing when it comes to passengers. I'm probably famous around the Access-A-Ride base, I joked. Then he gave me a piece of advice. No matter how bad drivers may be, try not to confront them personally, he said. Be careful. They know where you live.
有时我会向喜欢的司机抱怨那些我不喜欢的司机。我最喜欢的司机之一告诉我，当涉及到乘客时，司机也会做同样的事情。“我可能在Access-A-Ride基地很有名，”我开玩笑说。然后他给了我一个建议。“无论司机有多坏，尽量不要与他们发生个人冲突，”他说。“小心点。他们知道你住在哪里。”
Whether they realize it or not, I know the way many drivers treat me may be influenced by how I look and, by extension, what they think they can get away with in my presence. I'm a 5' 1" black woman on crutches. On an average day, most people are shocked when I open my mouth and they realize I'm not 16.
无论他们是否意识到，我知道许多司机对待我的方式可能受到我的外表的影响，进而影响到他们认为在我面前可以做些什么。我是个5英尺1英寸高、拄着拐杖的黑人女性。在平常的一天，大多数人在我开口说话并意识到我不是16岁时，都会感到震惊。
The worst thing a driver tried happened right outside my house just this summer. I was coming home from work. There was only one other passenger on board. He dropped her off at her apartment in Brooklyn, and my house was just 10 minutes away. I live on a quiet residential block. When the driver turned onto my street, I took my headphones off and began to gather my things. I knew that no one else was home, so I searched for my house keys and draped them around my neck.
今年夏天，司机试图做的最糟糕的事情就发生在我家门口。我下班回家。车上只有另一位乘客。他在布鲁克林的公寓把她放下，我家距离那里只有10分钟路程。我住在一条安静的住宅街区。当司机拐入我的街道时，我摘下耳机，开始收拾我的东西。我知道家里没别人，所以我找我的家门钥匙，把它挂在脖子上。
The driver pulled up to my house, opened the bus door, rose, and made an announcement. I've got to pee, he said. Had to go since I picked you up in Manhattan. I wondered why he felt the need to share this information. He grabbed a Styrofoam coffee cup and began walking toward me. I thought he was going to help me off the bus, so I prepared to hand him my crutches, but he didn't take them. I'm just going to go in this cup, he said. Then he sat in a seat across from me, began to unzip his fly, and I got it. He was going to pee right then and there.
司机把车停在我家门口，打开车门，站起来，宣布道。“我得尿尿，”他说。“从曼哈顿接你上来我就得尿了。”我不知道为什么他觉得有必要分享这个信息。他拿了一个聚苯乙烯泡沫咖啡杯，开始向我走来。我以为他要帮我下车，所以我准备把拐杖递给他，但他没接。“我正好在这个杯子里解决，”他说。然后他坐在我对面，开始拉开裤子拉链，我明白了。他打算就在那里当场小便。
As inappropriate and disgusting as it was, it wasn't physically harmful. Should I scream right now, I wondered? Would that be appropriate or would I be overreacting? Knowing that people with disabilities are more likely to be victims of sexual assault, I said a silent prayer to myself. I thought about just leaving my bag and trying to make a break for it. But with my crutches, I couldn't get off the bus on my own. I was just feet away from my house, but I couldn't get there. I wondered if he would have done this if I were white. I said nothing and turned my head away.
尽管这既不恰当又恶心，但它并没有造成身体伤害。我应该现在尖叫吗？我想知道。那样合适吗，还是我反应过度了？因为知道残疾人更有可能成为性侵犯的受害者，我对自己默默祈祷。我考虑过丢下行李直接冲出去。但拄着拐杖，我无法独自下车。我离家只有几英尺远，但我到不了那里。我想知道如果我是白人，他会这样做吗？我什么也没说，转过头去。
Years ago, when I was a teenager on this bus, I thought education would be the answer to all of my problems. But even with a law degree, I'm still a woman. I'm still black. And I'm still disabled. I thought, if this man does try anything more, your shiny Ivy League law degree will not save you. He finished with what he was doing and then he took my crutches to assist me in getting off the bus.
几年前，当我还是这辆车上的青少年时，我以为教育会是我所有问题的答案。但即使拥有法学学位，我仍然是一名女性。我仍然是黑人。我仍然是残疾人。我想，如果这个人尝试做任何进一步的事情，你那闪闪发光的常春藤盟校法律学位救不了你。他做完了他正在做的事，然后拿起我的拐杖帮我下车。
I hated the thought of him having to touch them, but I had no other choice. I handed him the bottom half, hoping that his hands wouldn't get anywhere near the handle part that I actually had to hold. As if nothing had happened, he asked if I also wanted him to hold my purse or my lunch bag. As I got off the bus, he offered to open my front gate for me. No, thank you, I said. I went inside as quickly as I could, washed my hands, wiped down my crutches, and called Transit to file a complaint.
我讨厌他必须触碰它们，但我别无选择。我把底部交给他，希望他的手不会靠近我真正必须握住的把手部分。好像什么都没发生过一样，他问我是否也需要他帮我拿钱包或午餐袋。我下车时，他主动提出帮我打开前门。不，谢谢，我说。我尽可能快地进屋，洗了手，擦了拐杖，然后打电话给交通部门投诉。
A few days later, Access-A-Ride told me the driver had been fired. And since then, thanks to that complaint and maybe all my other complaints, they seemed to be trying to address some of my issues. Sometimes I get better routing that gets me to work faster, which is nice, but not at all what I'm aiming for. I don't want them to fix it just for me. That's not fixing the problem. The problem is with the whole system. That's what I can't seem to get across to Access-A-Ride.
几天后，Access-A-Ride告诉我司机已被解雇。从那以后，多亏了那次投诉，也许还有我所有其他的投诉，他们似乎正在努力解决我的一些问题。有时我能得到更好的路线，让我更快到达工作地点，这很好，但这根本不是我的目标。我不想让他们只为我修复它。那不是解决问题。问题在于整个系统。这就是我似乎无法让Access-A-Ride理解的一点。
Once, when I was complaining to a representative about the roundabout two-hour routes they create for me and everyone else, the representative pointed out that, at least on that particular day, I'd made it to my destination on time. I explained that wasn't the point. You still want to file a complaint, even though you got there on time, he clarified? Yes. I don't understand the problem, then.
有一次，当我向代表抱怨他们为我和其他人创建的长达两小时的迂回路线时，代表指出，至少在那一天，我准时到达了目的地。我解释说那不是重点。“即使你准时到达了，你仍然想投诉？”他澄清说。“是的。”“那我不明白问题在哪儿。”
Britney Wilson. She practices civil rights law at the Center for Constitutional Rights in New York. A version of this story first appeared on the website Longreads, which is a great site, by the way. You can find that at longreads.com.
布兰妮·威尔逊。她在纽约宪法权利中心从事民权法律工作。这个故事的一个版本首次出现在Longreads网站上，顺便说一下，这是一个很棒的网站。你可以在longreads.com找到它。
Well, our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo. The people who put our show together includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Kimberly Henderson, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, BA Parker, Benjamin Phelan, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed.
好了，我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作。制作我们节目的团队包括埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、伊莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔、金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、BA·帕克（BA Parker）、本杰明·费兰（Benjamin Phelan）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Louisa Lim, the reporter who got stuck in a traffic jam in China in Act Two of our show today has a podcast about China called The Little Red Podcast.
路易莎·林，今天在我们的节目第二幕中被堵在中国的记者，有一个关于中国的播客叫做《小红播客》（The Little Red Podcast）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he really loves this one song from Hamilton that never made it into the musical. Maybe because of the name.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）。你知道，他真的很喜欢这首《汉密尔顿》（Hamilton）里从没放进音乐剧的一首歌。可能是因为那个名字吧。
Always been the burr of somebody's ass.
一直像是某人心里的芒刺。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。